Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Merhaba.
Bugün benden sonra çıkacak konuşmacılar
size geçmişteki problemlerden,
bugün bunları nasıl çözdüklerinden,
gelecek için umutlarından bahsedecek.
Hepsi bizi heyecanlandıracak,
hepsi bizi mutlu edecek aslında.
Ben onlardan farklı olarak bugün,
geçmişten günümüze gelen
ve artarak süren bir sorundan
bahsetmek istiyorum
ama önce bu sorunu en içten yaşayan,
hayatımdaki en önemli insan,
kardeşim Alper ile
tanıştırmak istiyorum sizi.
Alper, çok özel bir çocuk.
Mesela, bir kere dinlediği
şarkıyı ezberleyebiliyor
veya yıllar önce geçtiği sokağı,
tanıştığı kişiyi
yıllar sonra hatırlayabiliyor.
Sporda da çok başarılı mesela.
Paten kayıyor, bisiklete biniyor,
rüzgar sörfü yapıyor,
hatta tenis müsabakalarına bile katılıyor.
Alper'in bu kadar özel durumunun
yanında, çok da özel bir sorunu var.
Alper otizmli.
Otizm, üç yaşından önce başlayan,
beyin gelişini engelleyen,
ömür boyu süren
bir zihinsel rahatsızlık.
Otizmli çocuklar, otizmli olmayan
çocuklara göre, çok daha zor öğreniyorlar.
Şarkıyı bir kerede ezberleyen bir çocuğa,
alfabedeki bir harfi öğretmek,
binden fazla tekrar,
bir yıldan uzun süreyi alabiliyor.
Dikkat süreleri de çok kısa.
Herhangi bir şeye, özellikle de eğitime,
beş dakikadan fazla
odaklanamıyorlar aslında.
Fiziksel olarak bizle aynı olsalar da,
fiziksel davranış bozuklukları var.
Bu bazen, mesela sürekli olarak dönen
bir çamaşır makinesine bakmak
veya aynı oyuncakla takıntılı
bir şekilde oynamak şeklinde
kendini gösterebildiği gibi,
çoğu zaman onlara zarar verecek şekilde,
kendilerine vurmak veya
bağırmak şeklinde de gözükebiliyor.
Otizmli çocukların yüzde ellisi,
hayatlarının uzun bir döneminde;
yüzde otuzu, hayatları
boyunca hiç konuşamıyor.
Konuşabilen otizmli çocuklar,
göz teması kurmaktan çekiniyor,
sosyal etkileşimde sorunlar yaşıyor.
Etrafınızda kaç otizmli çocuk gördünüz?
Veya kaç insandan biri otizmli,
diye sormak daha doğru.
Biliyor musunuz bilmiyorum ama,
otizm sandığınızdan çok daha yaygın.
Her yeni doğan altmış sekiz çocuktan
biri, otizmli olarak doğuyor.
Bu, bütün kanser hastalarının, üç
katı kadar otizmli birey var demek.
Sadece Türkiye'de, 0-18 yaş
352 bin otizmli çocuk var.
Büyük soru ise, otizmin çözümü ne.
Otizmin neden kaynaklandığını
bilmediğimiz için tıbbi bir çözümü de yok.
Tek çözüm yöntemi; haftada kırk
saati bulan, üç yaşından önce başlayan
erken ve yoğun eğitim almaları,
ama Türkiye'deki otizmli çocukların,
sadece yüzde beşi eğitim alabiliyor.
Yüzde doksan beşi, kaderlerine
terk ediliyor, çünkü bu çocuklar
devlet okullarına kabul edilmiyorlar.
Özel eğitim, rehabilitasyon merkezi
adındaki özel kurumlara gitmek zorunda
bırakılıyorlar, ki bu kurumlarda da
yeterli eğitim saatini alamıyorlar.
Otizmli olmayan bir çocuk,
devlet okullarında haftada
otuz saat eğitim alabilirken,
tek umudu eğitim olan
otizmli olan bir çocuk,
bütün öğrenme bozukluklarına rağmen,
dikkat dağınıklıklarına rağmen,
haftada iki saatlik eğitime
mahkûm ediliyor
ve bu nedenle de, eğitim çok pahalı.
Aileler eksik kalan eğitimi tamamlamak
için, özel okullara, kurumlara,
öğretmenlere gitmek zorunda bırakılıyor.
Otizmli çocuğa sahip bir Türk ailesi,
ortalama olarak asgari ücretin
iki katından daha fazla parayı
sadece eğitime harcıyor.
Kardeşim şanslı bir çocuktu.
Yeterli eğitimi alabildi.
Bugün bizimle, aynı salonda
beni izleyebildi.
Bunun yanı sıra Alper, onun kadar
şanslı olmayan arkadaşları için de
bana çok büyük bir ilham verdi.
Bundan beş sene önce, ilk
akıllı telefonumu aldığımda,
kardeşimin akıllı cihazlara olan
yoğun ilgisini fark ettim.
O zamanlar konuşamayan,
okuma yazma bilmeyen çocuk,
akıllı telefonumu kullanabiliyor,
sadece fotoğrafları ezberleyerek
Youtube'da istediği şarkıyı açabiliyor
veya fotoğraflarla benimle
iletişim kurmayı deniyordu.
O an, kardeşime bir tablet edindim ve onu
tablet bilgisayarlarla eğitmeyi amaçladım.
Ama şimdi daha büyük bir sorunum vardı.
Otizmli çocuklar için geliştirilmiş
uygulamalar yoktu.
Normal çocuklar için geliştirilen
uygulamalar ise ya onlara çok zor geliyor
ya da onlara zarar verebilecek
içerikliklere sahip olabiliyorlardı.
Alper'den aldığım ilhamla, o zamanlar
bir mobil oyun şirketinde
bilgisayar mühendisi
olarak çalışırken ben,
işimden istifa edip
ODTÜ'den arkadaşım Sercan'la beraber,
OTSIMO'yu yarattık.
OTSIMO, otizmli çocuklar
ve aileleri için geliştirilmiş ücretsiz
bir mobil uygulama aslında.
Çocuk uygulamasının içinde,
çocuklar için geliştirilmiş,
onlarca farklı eğitsel oyun var.
Bu oyunları, Tohum Otizm Vakfı
işbirliği ile alanındaki uzman kişilerle
beraber geliştiriyoruz, onların
ihtiyaçları için tasarlıyoruz.
Otsimo'da her oyundan veri topluyoruz.
Çocukların nelerde zorlandığını
anlayıp onlar için yapay zeka ile beraber
otomatik öneriler çıkartıyoruz.
Mesela A harfini çizemeyen bir
çocuğun oyun zorluğunu düşürüyor,
A harfini daha çok göstermeye başlıyoruz.
Aile uygulamasında aileler, çocukları
hakkındaki bütün bilgilere erişebiliyorlar
mesela analiz bölümünde karnelerini
görüp nelerde eksik olduklarını görüp
eğitimlerini buna göre
şekillendirebiliyorlar.
Eğitim bölümünde aileleri de
eğitmeyi amaçlıyoruz.
Bu sayede ailelerin, otizm eğitiminde
etkin bir rol oynamasını istiyoruz.
Yine çocuklarına uygun oyunları bulup
bu oyunun ayarlarını
uzaktan değiştirebiliyorlar.
Peki biz neden akıllı cihazlarla
çocukları eğitmeye çalışıyoruz?
Biliyoruz ki, araştırmalar gösteriyor ki,
eğer otizmli çocuklara şans verirsek,
erken ve yoğun eğitim alabilirlerse,
bu çocukların yüzde doksanı
bizimle aynı okullarda okuyabiliyor,
bizimle aynı hayatı yaşayabiliyor,
bizimle aynı ortamda bulunabiliyor.
Amacımız, eksik kalan
bu 38 saatlik eğitimi,
aileleri de eğiterek akıllı cihazlar
yardımıyla evde vermek.
Bir yıldan kısa sürede,
on binden fazla çocuğa,
yüz bin saatten fazla eğitime ulaştırdık.
İletişim güçlüğü çeken otizmli çocuklar,
OTSİMO uygulaması aracılığıyla üç yüz
binden fazla kelimeyi konuştular.
Arkamda gördüğünüz
Baran da bunlardan biri.
Baran OTSİMO'nun ilk kullanıcılarından.
OTSİMO'dan önce bir buçuk sene boyunca
o iki saatlik eğitime gidiyordu aslında.
Sadece OTSİMO'yu iki ay kullanarak Baran,
şu an bir devlet okuluna kabul aldı
ve arkadaşlarıyla aynı okulda,
yaşıtlarıyla aynı okulda okuyabiliyor.
Benim için de en önemlisi,
kardeşimin hayatında bir
şeyler değiştirmeye başladım.
Onunla beraber eğitim materyallerini
tasarladım, onunla beraber deneyimledim,
onunla beraber öğrendim.
Bugün buraya gelmekteki amacım,
ne otizm hakkında internette
bulabileceğiniz verileri size söylemek,
ne de aslında
OTSİMO'da yaptıklarımızı anlatmaktı.
Bugün buraya sizden
yardım istemeye geldim,
beraber bir değişim yaratmaya geldim.
Arkamda gördüğünüz okul, kardeşimle
beraber on otizmli çocuğun okuduğu okuldu.
Havuzunda yüzmeyi öğreniyorlar,
karşısındaki denizde
rüzgar sörfü yapabiliyorlardı.
Okuluydu, yapabiliyorlardı diyorum
çünkü sadece otizmli olduğu için,
onları farklı bulduğu için etraflarındaki
insanlar, onları bu binayı terk etmek,
bu okulu bırakmak zorunda bıraktılar.
Şimdi bu imkânların çoğuna
da erişemiyorlar aslında.
Sadece kardeşim de değil,
Alican'ı duymuşsunuzdur,
14 yaşında, kardeşimle aynı yaşta,
otizmli, annesi babası terk etmiş,
dedesi tarafından bakılıyor.
Her zaman yaptığımız gibi bizim,
sadece evine gitmek için minibüsü
kullanmak istiyor Alican,
dedesiyle beraber
minibüse biniyorlar beş ay önce.
Sadece otizmli olduğu için,
sadece bizden farklı olduğu için,
sadece ses çıkardığı için Alican,
o minibüsteki vicdansız insanlar
yüzünden minibüsten indiriliyor,
hatta dedesi hakarete uğruyor.
Konuşmanın başında, size üç yüz binden
fazla otizmli çocuktan bahsettim.
Eğitim alamayan otizmli çocuktan.
Bu çocukların neden o iki saatlik
kuş kadar eğitime bile gitmediğini
düşündünüz mü?
Bu çocukların aileleri vicdansız değil,
bu çocukların aileleri de en az
çocuklarını bizim kadar seviyorlar,
bizim kadar iyi olmasını istiyorlar.
Bu çocukların eğitim
almasını biz engelliyoruz.
İstedikleri okulda okuyacakları
zaman onları okullarından ediyor,
sadece okullarına gitmek için ulaşım
haklarını kullanmak istedikleri zaman,
onları minibüsten indiriyoruz.
Otizmli çocukların aileleri,
diğer ailelerden farklı olarak,
çocuklarının onlardan
önce ölmesini isterler.
Bir aileye bunu diletecek, bunu
yaşatacak kadar ne yapmış olabiliriz ki?
O yüzden bugün sizden yardım istiyorum.
Bir otizmli çocuk gördüğünüz zaman,
ona yardım edin,
onun elinden tutun.
Ailesi güçsüz olduğu zaman,
ona ses olun.
Ancak o zaman onların
eğitim almasını sağlayabiliriz,
ancak o zaman onların
bizimle beraber yaşamasını sağlayabiliriz,
ancak o zaman geleceği beraber
değiştirebiliriz. Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)